schaut euch meine augen an ich glaube
wir hätten
mein name ist luca herzlich willkommen
zu einem facebook wir schon ein bisschen
vorbei aber ich hab mir gedacht hey ich
meine ich wenn ich meine augen zumache
einmal wieder zu bin so hässlich ich bin
leonardo capri sonne cabrio leonardo und
cabrio mach ich habe letztens lost a
common law nicht so leicht vielleicht
habe ich auch nicht nein vielleicht doch
schön wenn ich will dass alle rentner
leben zudem bin ich werfe mich zwischen
oz gibt gewinnen weil panik schwach ihr
freunde 14 und dem vielleicht im titanic
wenn ich dich diesmal auf ein brett zu
liegen
ich bin locker denn die teile hier
bewegen sich wenn ich mich meinen
dafür brauche ich tatsächlich zwei
gesichter aber ihr könnt euch vielleicht
noch an das saturn video erinnern wo ich
das waren jan placement ich verlinke
euch das einfach mal hier da irgendwo
und da wurden ja bilder von mir gemacht
und 3d bilder und die figuren sind
angekommen
das ist das ultra fans binden das bin
ich in
und die woche geil deswegen habe ich
auch schon den titel gelesen
wahrscheinlich facebook mit mir selbst
ich versuche das nämlich jetzt einfach
mal ich dachte das passt ist nicht mein
eigenes gesicht ach du heilige scheiße
mann wie krank ist das denn
ich weiß nicht die anderen ein bisschen
kleiner eine chance mit der auch
irgendwie witzig wäre jetzt wenn es mit
den beiden figuren klappt wie soll ich
das denn jetzt machen mit dem handy er
gut man sieht jetzt keinen so krassen
unterschied es ist auf jeden fall
möglich die beiden tauschen rate ihre
gesichter aber es ist natürlich viel
witziger wenn es einfach egal ich hab
euch einen link dazu eine beschreibung
gepackt wenn ihr auch bockhop durch so
eine kleine figur von euch zu machen ich
bekomme dafür kein geld als jetzt sage
ich find's einfach und das mit diesem
das war es jetzt tatsächlich auch mit
meinem tripod dass mit diesen figuren
geklappt hat frage ich mich jetzt
natürlich auch ob es mit nein natürlich
nicht was ist wenn ich mal rein
theoretisch geht das nicht bei snap chat
kann man ja auch sein gesicht erkennen
lassen und so einen schwachsinn dann
irgendwie machen oder so war sondern
beispielsweise auch mal ihr könnt mich
übrigens natürlich als der laser luca
das erfahrt ihr wir nicht spaghetti
kochen unter fehler und so herr kemal
balu hier ich will hier geht das auch
nicht was ist wenn ich hier einfach
meine figur nehme wird auch nicht und
wenn ich hier einfach mal ukulele nehme
wenig freunde
leben ich hab gerade 17 joints geraucht
schotter ich meine augen belaufen
mein präsident hat mich dahin geschickt
von amerika hellmann name ist osama bin
laden barack obama schicken leute von
mir zwei gesichter ins sichtfeld durch
und wir moderieren
ich bin ja ich alle leute sagen mein
name ich weggehe anfang in hogwarts
einstein und einstein harry potter kann
man ja so witzig mit diesen figuren
machen sie jetzt ich habe mir auch noch
die app facebook live heruntergeladen wo
es angeblich auch möglich ist irgendwas
zu machen ich weiß aber nicht geht dass
jetzt nicht hier mit kohle oder geht es
zumindest mit balu und wenn ich ihn nie
wieder rein packe sehen wir nicht mal
das funktioniert weil donald trump und
ich bin so ein hallo ich bin donald
trump kaufen und jetzt habe ich einen
kunden und ein kleines gesicht jetzt wo
es meine nase ja ich bin wie du bist ein
brett bailey hat mit us-präsident bei
dem anderen den beiden besser gefallen
haben ist offen
kopf malaria eine dj schule kita
leonardo capri sonne zurück imbiss muss
leider jetzt wirken unterschätzen wir
selber auch einen der petzen zwar lustig
nennen aber das seht ihr euch schied
leider vorbei
doch einfach mal was mein fucking
dauwalter mit mir meinen daumen hoch